- Hi guys, it's Inga.
(upbeat music)
- Hi, I'm Adrienne Borlongan,
I'm on of the co-founders
of Wanderlust Creamery.
We're an artisanal ice cream shop,
we make everything in house
and all of our flavors
are inspired by travel.
Today we're having Inga
coming to make some ice cream,
it's gonna be really fun.
- I'm finally here, I
wanted to do something today
that kind of represents my background.
I'm half Taiwanese and I'm
half Hong Kong Chinese.
- All the best desserts come from there.
- Yes, Hong Kong egg tarts are so popular.
- That custard flavor, put in some shards
of flaky, caramelized puff pastry.
- Oh my god, sounds so good.
Oolong tea is super big in Taiwan.
Mom would always buy pineapple pastries.
- Maybe we can do an
oolong infused ice cream
with some pineapple
pastry pieces in there.
- Let's do it!
(pleasant music)
- We're gonna start with our base.
Organic grass fed dairy,
eggs, a little bit of sugar.
For this one, we're using 16% butter fat
because we want it a little richer.
- This looks super creamy.
- We're gonna add some Taiwanese oolong.
I picked this variety because it's known
for having like a really
buttery, milky flavor.
- I love that.
- We're just gonna heat
that until it infuses.
- Look at this, swirly.
- [Adrienne] Basically bringing the base
to just a low simmer.
- Oh, you can actually
smell it, this is so cool.
- And now we're gonna
take this and strain it.
- Y'all ready?
Oh my god, you can actually see
this many tea leaves in there, I love it.
We did it.
- Press down really hard on that.
- You squeeze it all
out, is it coming out?
Oh my god.
Okay.
- Do you wanna taste your concoction?
- Oh, it tastes like
really creamy boba tea
and it's not bitter, this is so good.
I would just eat it like this.
- We're gonna cut up our pineapple pastry.
- [Inga] Sheer pineapple goodness.
(pleasant music)
- Now that we have the
oolong tea already done,
we're gonna set that one aside
and we're gonna start with our
Hong Kong egg tart ice cream.
We're gonna separate some egg yolks.
(metallic clanking)
- Okay, there we go, egg whites in here.
- [Adrienne] Yes.
- Wow, I am really bad at this today.
Yes!
- Oh.
- Oh sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry.
- It's okay.
(laughing)
- I'm sorry!
- I have a spoon, don't worry.
- I did it, beautiful.
- We're adding our base again,
we're adding extra egg
yolks to make it really.
- Extra yolk-y.
- Let's heat this baby up, break it up.
This is pretty much warm.
You're just gonna put a little splash.
- Beautiful color.
- And then you're gonna add that to this.
Does that smell familiar to you?
- That does!
- To give it more egg flavor,
we're using this Indian
ingredient called black salt.
- This is labeled egg farts.
- It's literally labeled egg farts
because it smells like egg fart, smell it.
- Okay, yeah, it does smell like it.
- This is what they
use to make vegan eggs,
it gives it more of that egg flavor
without adding actual egg.
- You don't want it tasting
too much like farts.
- Yeah, if we add too much egg,
it's gonna ruin the
consistency of the ice cream.
Cheers!
- Cheers!
- Super egg-y.
- It tastes exactly like egg tart,
like a creamier, eggier version of it.
- Only thing missing is the crust.
I baked up some sticks of puff pastry,
so that when you scoop,
these kind of just break
and you can see the flakes.
- Custard and then pastry.
- Exactly.
- Like a never ending egg tart.
- Well now we're gonna go ahead
and pour this mix into
the ice cream machine.
- Okay, let's go.
- This is a Ferrari of ice cream machines,
this is the Carpigiani LV502G.
Carpigiani.
- Carpigiani.
Lamborghini.
- We pour the mix in here
and the mix gets whipped
with a blade as the barrel
freezes the ice cream,
creating super tight
microscopic ice crystals.
- Got it.
Oh my god, this is some epic
egg tart waterfall right here.
To the very last drop.
- Put the lid on and I'm gonna have you
press the magic button.
- Here we go.
In eight minutes, we'll come back.
(whimsical music)
- I'm gonna open the gate.
- Okay, open it, oh my god!
This is like, what game
is this, like Tetris?
(upbeat synth music)
Okay, go.
(upbeat music)
It's not stopping, help.
- Here, I'll trade you.
- Help.
So here we are.
- Almost four gallons.
Just stick them in and
they're gonna get broken up.
All the way down, fill that baby up.
- [Inga] Yeah.
- [Adrienne] And then
let's just cover them up.
- [Inga] Oh yeah.
- Gonna cover this with some paper
and we're just gonna throw it
right here in our blast freezer.
We're gonna let it sit
for about 15 minutes.
- We did it, first ice cream, check.
- Alright, now let's do
the oolong ice cream.
- Round two!
(cheery whistling)
- No!
- [Adrienne] Open the floodgate.
- Yeah, I'm scared.
(cheery whistling)
Okay, go, go, go, go, go!
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
This is giving me a panic
attack, oh my goodness.
(rhythmic saxophone music)
So now we keep on waiting.
(clock rapidly ticking)
- Alright, let's peel
back this oolong ice cream
with pineapple pastry bits.
- Oolong, oolong.
- There you go.
- Ta-da!
This smells like Taiwan.
But now we should do one of this
and then one of the egg custard.
This is the Hong Kong egg tart!
Look at how the puff pastry breaks apart.
I'm so excited, this is
me in ice cream form.
A little bit of this,
a little bit of that.
I love the oolong flavor, the
creaminess of the custard,
it reminds me of home, this is amazing.
We did it!
(cheering)
So if you guys wanna eat this too,
you should go to Wanderlust
Creamery right now
because it's only gonna be
there for a short while.
I promise you, it will be worth the trip.
(laughing)
(pleasant music)
- Hey, Unsolved is on a new
channel, and now your part.
Subscribe here.
- Subscribe here.
That was my part.